and i go somewhere and they're like the
controversial mariam namazi
and yesterday they had a an islamist who
says that people like me should be
killed
but that's not controversial
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you
if you're bored with people arguing on
the internet over subjects they know
nothing about a trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts
we ask the experts our fantastic guest
this week is a spokesperson for the
council of
ex-muslims welcome to trigonometry thank
you
it's a pleasure to be here
[Music]
thank you so much for coming and for
anyone who doesn't know a lot of people
will obviously will know who you are but
for people who don't
uh tell us a little bit just a little
bit about your backstory and how have
you come to be so passionate about the
issues that you talk about that we'll
get into
well i'm originally from iran and so
i and i was raised as a muslim of course
and after the iranian revolution
it became an islamic state even though
the revolution was an islamic
so we left the country so i
became involved in refugee rights issues
given my own experiences of course
opposition to the islamic state because
it was
just horrible you know to live under it
and
the results of it continues to today and
so that's
what i've sort of been campaigning on
issues around islam islamism women's
rights
secularism and of course refugee rights
and i have so many questions to ask you
we both do
most of which i'm quite reluctant to ask
because these are very difficult
issues to talk about so can you just
outline for us first of all
one of the things i think is really
important to d market is the difference
between muslims is people
islam is a religion and islamism as a
more of a you probably would say
political
ideology so can you just explain to us
and our viewers
what are those things and how to
separate them yeah i mean i think it's
quite
simple to separate them i don't know why
everybody has a difficult task doing it
and i think if you compare it with cr
the christian right because a lot of
progressive people
will be against the church for example
against its
laws regarding women for example
the christian rights assault on abortion
rights reproductive rights women's
rights for example in the u.s
or in poland and then there's
christianity
which a lot of free thinkers will make
fun of christianity
will make fun of jesus for example you
have comedy shows
with jesus in a nappy and then you've
got christians
and you can make fun of christianity and
make fun of the christian right oppose
the christian right
and nobody says you're attacking
christians you know or you're bigoted
against christians it's
the exact same thing i don't know why
it's so difficult to understand
you know we come from muslim backgrounds
a lot of our family members are still
muslims
so and and don't you know racists can't
tell any one of us apart anyway
so if you think that you know for us we
think oh we're safe because they're only
going to attack the muslims
i mean they attack sikhs thinking
they're muslims they can't tell anyone
from anyone
you know so in in we don't want to be
inciting racism
racism affects ex-muslims too it affects
our families too
but it's a question of saying look we're
we're free thinkers
uh we want to criticize the islamic
right
we like the christian right we want to
be able to criticize islam as a
ridiculous idea as all religions are
but that's not the same as attacking
muslims that's not the same as attacking
people and i think
it you know it's something that's
conflated as a way really of silencing
criticism i mean that's what's happened
and
the islamic movement is doing that you
know trying to silence criticism
it's a way of imposing blasphemy laws
here in europe where
blasphemy laws don't exist so in iran
nobody will accuse you of
islamophobia or bigotry against muslims
they'll call you an apostate
a blasphemer and you go to prison and
you get the death penalty for it
here they use terms like islamophobia
as a and and bigotry and racism as a way
of imposing those laws
uh you know de facto rather than in the
law do you know what i mean
i do know what you mean but here's where
the difficulty comes in because
i understand i both of us are
non-believers and we also think that
there's a lot of problems with all
religions
uh maybe islam in particular has certain
challenges as well but if one of us was
to say what you've just said
well that's it we're islamophobic we're
racist we're bigoted
and that and that is difficult isn't it
well i mean we get accused of that too
so it's it's people who are
from you get accused of being
islamophobic of course yeah i've inside
of being
uncle toms of being coconuts of
being a native informants you know
of of promoting a neo-colonial agenda
these are things they say to us as well
and i think that you know it's good that
people are concerned about racism that's
thanks to
a huge anti-racist movement that has
made it difficult
to be racist and bigoted that's
something positive and
i think it's nice that people are
concerned about racism
and that's a great thing you know but i
think it's important to say that
you know great that we're concerned with
racism but criticizing the religious
right or criticizing bad ideas
has nothing to do with racism and i do
understand that
you have a far right that is very savvy
like the islamists are very savvy they
use human
rights language they even use
anti-racist language
as a way of covering themselves you know
so you'll have the edl or tommy robinson
or britain first and these sort of
groups saying we're not
attacking muslims we're anti-islam and
were anti-islamism using this sort of
language as well
but really you can see that their
politics are focused on
migrants on muslims on deportations on
keeping people out on never
recognizing people of different
backgrounds are citizens
and equal citizens you know they're
always the other
they never really belong according to
them uh the the proper europe is a white
christian europe according to them so
you can see how people can get confused
because you do have the far right
using similar language but i think you
know again i think it's very simple
it's like i say i'm a women's rights
campaigner
george bush said he attacked iraq for
women's rights well
who do you believe do you know what i
mean it's simple if someone's actually
killing women
and saying they're protecting them if
they're throwing bombs on countries
and saying it's for human rights well
then i think your brain can work a
little bit and say
well they're they're pretending in the
same way that the islamists say
islam is a religion of peace while
they're beheading you you know so
i think you can tell the difference and
i think it's just
asking people to use their critical
faculties you know
when it comes to islam it seems as if
everybody has a lobotomy you know
the same uh principles
and ethics we would use on other issues
somehow when it comes to islam
we're incapable of doing it before
francis jump in let me just finish this
line of questioning he never lets me
talk
it's better for everybody that way i'm
very rushing of you
yes i talk i ask questions
you listen
just give me one more um
you mentioned this phrase islam is a is
a religion of peace
yeah and whenever there's a terrorist
attack
by islamists and jihadis in this country
or anywhere else in europe
that seems to always be the line
islam is a religion of peace you can't
talk about it
even open-minded people like us who want
to understand what
where different people are coming from
and they're not blaming whole groups of
people for certain things
you can't say that particularly as a
white person you can't say that but even
as you said yourself as someone who's
from iran
from was brought up as a muslim you know
saying islam is not a religion of peace
which i imagine you believe
it's impossible so can you just talk to
us about why you don't think
islam is a religion i mean i don't think
any religion is a religion of peace i
mean religion
is based on you know murdering anyone
who is a
heretic an apostate you know you've got
the spanish inquisitions
we've got historical examples we've got
present-day examples
and the islamic movement has power in
many countries they're actually
crucifying people in the street
hanging people off of cranes for
apostasy for blasphemy for being gay
they're stoning people to death in the
streets so
you know it's not a hypothetical
discussion to say that
islam or any religion is not peaceful i
think religion actually
is you know the antithesis of peace
and justice and in fact you know it's
funny because they always talk about
religious morality
but really it's immorality from an
ethical point of view you know
so many of you know just to give you an
example in islam
it's immoral to have sex outside of
marriage so you have sex with someone
you love
but it's perfectly fine to have child
marriage which is pedophilia and child
rape
you know it's it's uh it's not possible
to hold hands with your partner someone
you love on the street because that's
considered
sexual mixing but it's perfectly fine to
specify the size of stone to stone
someone to death
for having an adulterous relationship or
for um
being a homosexual it's perfectly fine
to throw someone off a building because
they're gay
but you know it's haram to eat during
ramadan
i mean it's just the the unethical
nature of all religious precepts i think
it's clear i mean i i
i think the problem is because religion
is treated with such kid gloves
and there's so much respect for
something that is so not worthy of any
respect you know
and so i i know you don't look very
happy sorry no no no no
no no no that [ __ ] that's my face
because i get that a lot when i'm
speaking people like my friends
probably agrees with you even more than
i have okay so yeah so i think yeah so
saying islam is a religion of peace it's
just
you know it's nonsense it's not true by
any measure
you just have to you know yeah they'll
say and and let me say this
my dad who's a muslim is the loveliest
kindest person in the world he wouldn't
hurt a fly
so again i'm not saying that muslims are
like that
or christians are like what the bible
says or jews are like what the torah
says you know in in the torah for
example
men pray thanking god that they weren't
born women you know
there's so many examples of that in all
religions so
i because i think people are better than
their religions because people
change according and adapt according to
the age that they live in
and books really remain the same and
that's why interpretation is such a big
thing because people do interpret things
the way they want
but i think islam is not at all peaceful
and i understand why people say it
because they don't want muslims to be
targeted and rightfully so
you know now in sri lanka after the
attack on the church
muslims are being dragged out of their
homes their shops are being burnt down
they haven't done
anything you know and we've got lots of
ex-muslims who've had to flee the city
because of course they're also
considered muslims
and they've lost their homes they're
homeless so again
you can understand why people say that
but i think that's going about it the
wrong way
because you know everybody knows that's
not true and you're just
helping to not discuss the truth and
you're
sort of making muslims a target by not
saying the truth about things you know
and
i think that's where we need to be very
clear target believes target religious
right movements
never ever is targeting people
permissible in any circumstance
i mean i think that's a very very
important and powerful message
because you do see a lot of you know
people targeting individual people
you know you know you get horrible
stories about hijabs getting ripped
off people and it's just absolutely
heartbreaking
the the words that i hear banded about
all the time and that i hear and
that we've used already in this
interview is islamophobia
and i don't even know what that means
could you
clarify for myself and for the listeners
what is
what what what is the meaning of the
word and what it would be
how is it used and sometimes i see in
order to shut down
debate and conversation yeah i mean i
think
there's a big problem with this word and
the problem is
that one it's become mainstream so it's
adopted by the un it's adopted by
various
uh you know in british now the british
government has adopted it and lots of
parties are adopting it and
um the there's an all-parliamentary
group that's
uh also put forward this word this term
and explained it
and basically it implies that there's
it's bigotry against muslims but it's
you know there's a problem because it
sort of uses the word islam which is a
religion
rather than saying muslim phobia i would
be perfectly happy with that term like
xenophobia which is
a phobia against foreigners like
homophobia a phobia against
gay people these are discrimination and
bigotry against
people gay people migrants muslims
but islamophobia is islam is an idea and
it's fine if people have a phobia of it
you know i have a phobia about fascism
you know i don't like it and i i'll
stand up against it wherever i can
it's the same with religion for me i do
have a phobia a dislike
of religions as well you know and so to
compare that with
bigotry against people is really
problematic
um and it's um it's something that is
being used as a way of
somehow conflating criticism of islam
criticizing
islamism with an attack on muslims and
and so it becomes
impossible to really say anything for a
lot of people
i did a stint of work when i was a
supply teacher and i worked
in an islamic primary school in south
london
and uh in the afternoon the children had
islamic studies as it was called and
they sat down and these were children in
year two
you didn't teach them
and it sounds awful in my accent as well
but
however i do have a racist voice i
realized that
but um there was one point because i sat
in and i had to observe it and all the
rest of it and then i marked books at
the back
and i remember the imam sat down with
his children who was six and seven years
old
and was talking about jesus and he said
um explain that the reason that jesus
was murdered was because the jews were
jealous of him
and he repeated the jews four or five
times
and at this point i was sitting there
going at what point does this
start to creep into indoctrination these
children have no idea of judaism or
what a jewish person is and repeating
the words you know the jews killed him
that you know and the jews because they
were jealous of him
and i'm just there and i i got
incredibly uncomfortable at that point
that you've got these children who are
completely innocent
and repeating the word jews constantly
and
saying that they're the reason that
jesus died
yeah i mean that's one of the basis of
anti-semitism as well isn't it i mean
even anti not just islamic anti-semitism
but christian anti-semitism too
and i think again this is why it's
really important that we don't have
religion in schools i think religion is
fine as
we teach history or you know uh in the
sense of talking about
different religions so people know you
know that there are different religions
in the world but that they're also
people who are atheists and humanists
and free thinkers
and and not as a form of indoctrination
but historically what religions have
done
because they've done a lot of bad [ __ ]
in the world you know and it would be
good for kids to know that rather than
always having this
religion is this religion is all lovely
and cuddly
whilst also giving really sinister
messages about
the religion that you don't like you
know or you want your
the kids to move away from and i think
it does lead to indoctrination i mean
even in
christian schools which are not as bad
as islamic schools today
right you do have this concept of heaven
and hell
and it does instill fear in children you
know it's quite abusive when you the
psychological abuse of it is quite
harsh especially if if kids believe it
and it scares them
and i've met lots of k you know adults
who were really frightened of these
concepts
when they were children and it can be
such a scary thing so i think
it's it's good for kids to learn about
things but not in a way that
indoctrinates them having an imam come
to school
is really i think you know it's
dangerous for for children
and uh it's um it is because they do
have this idea of indoctrination in mind
i don't know if you saw i i wish i had
the details of it but there was this
um i think i'm gonna say in egypt there
was this uh the saudi government
had given a lot of money uh for a
sort of a theological department
at this university and i was reading how
the professor was chair of that
department
had been fired because the saudi uh
one of the representatives of the saudi
government was wanting to see his notes
and wanted him to say things like islam
is a better religion
than the other religions and he was
angry that he was also teaching other
religions and not just islam
so it does you know there is a lot of
indoctrination and this idea of
indoctrination
and trying to veer people to thinking
islam is the best religion
and what does that come with you know
the fact that girls and boys need to be
separate girls need to be modest
and be covered up uh you know they
shouldn't
sing their voices shouldn't be too loud
they shouldn't laugh out loud they
shouldn't be in sports
that's all the things that it comes with
and imagine saying this to
little kids you know you heard the
jewish sermon
but there's all this other sermons as
well about girls and modesty
and um you know superiority of
boys which is so detrimental to child
development
and where do you actually stand on the
hijab do you and
at what point do you think because i
taught in a primary school
and you'd see little girls of the age of
five six years old and they'd be wearing
them sometimes even younger
yeah where would you where do you stand
on it do you agree with it do you
disagree and why
well i mean i think first of all five or
six year olds it even goes against
islamic teachings because you're not
supposed to
wear the veil until you're a woman and
that's after puberty right so
um like in iran for example it's when
you start going to school at the age of
seven
i know a lot of families living in the
west they
veil their kids younger because they
know if they let them not be veiled
until they're seven or eight
they're not going to want to wear it
anymore because you do really feel the
restriction of it
and so i think part of it is just trying
to get them used to it
like caging a bird you know you get used
to it and then it becomes natural for
you and you kind of feel naked if you
don't go out if you go out with it so i
think
but on the veil i think it's there's no
yes right
or wrong answer in the sense that i
think it's more complex
for me for me i think child veiling is a
form of child abuse
because the veil represents basically
tells a girl that
her body is something that causes
fitness or chaos in society if it's not
covered up so
i had someone in a debate in britain
tell me an imam
say that if we don't have gender
segregation which again the veil
is a symbol of it segregates you from
men if you don't have gender segregation
it's going to lead to adultery
and sex and we're going to have to stone
people so isn't it better that we have
gender segregation and we veil women
so this is the the perverted ethical you
know
unethical really mindset of a religion
obsessed with women's bodies obsessed
with girls bodies
so i do think with girls it's so
unethical because they don't get
sunlight in their hair
what it means is they have to be
separate from boys so you can't be
friends with boys anymore
you can't swim you can't dance uh you
know you have to sit at the back of the
classroom that's all what it represents
so it affects child development
and what does it tell a girl growing up
that you know your body is so disgusting
that's why we all have such huge body
image problems you know
i mean women everywhere do but we
especially you know our bodies are
filthy
you know according to how we've been
raised you know
which is why i did nude protest as well
because it was so difficult for me
but also a way of just saying i'm not
gonna allow that to
to take hold but when it comes to adult
women i think
you know if a woman wants to wear a veil
well you know she has a right to wear a
veil
and i use the term right um you know
carefully because
rights are meant to liberate you not to
oppress you but i think that people if
they want to wear it they can
as adults but child veiling is child
abuse and i think if you represent
a secular state like as a teacher or if
you're a judge
then you shouldn't be wearing religious
symbols you know
so i have but on the border i think it
should be banned basically
because i do think it's a body bag for
women and it's just so
i mean people who defend it should
actually walk in it for
for half an hour to see how it feels
it is like being buried alive in my
opinion
right well and the thing you say about
people's rights as well i mean
from what i know a lot of women are put
in the position where
they they're not forced to but you know
they're very strongly encouraged to wear
the veil or the burqa because male
relatives insist on it or whatever
that's not really a right that someone's
exercising is it that's a form of
compulsion being used coercion coercion
yeah definitely i think
you know this whole idea of saying it's
a right and a choice
is um it's it's the fact that you've
submitted to something doesn't make it a
right and choice you know and i think
that's the distinction
yeah you you can submit to a lot of
things uh
even though you you might not want to
but that's just the way things are meant
to be and you have to do them sort of
thing
and there's so much pressure you know i
mean if you like talk to a lot of
ex-muslims um you know who obviously
they look muslim they live in muslim
areas
and you know they're not fasting the
pressure you know you're not fasting
um you know the sort of there's this
constant pressure so you end up then
hiding if you're eating or you pretend
that you are
you know so yeah you can say they've
chosen not to fast but it's not that
easy when you
are in that situation at the veil also
you know
people will say it's a choice but i'd
ask those same women if you want to
remove that veil today would you be able
to do it
and most likely no you know most likely
it would be very very difficult
to remove the veil uh near impossible
you would and we've had members who've
done it you lose
everything in many instances your family
your friends
you know and everyone that you knew um
and so it's it's you know if it doesn't
sound like a right
no exactly if you have a right to
something you should have a right to go
in and out of it when you choose
if you have a right to religion you have
a right to leave religion when it's not
that simple then there's a problem isn't
there
you know and i think with the veil
that's exactly the case and it just
i find it incredible that you just
referred to yourself as an ex-muslim i
was raised catholic i went to catholic
school i would never refer to myself as
an ex-catholic i just got
i'm an atheist and i don't believe it
anymore and it was as simple as that but
it
it doesn't sound as simple as that in
islam yeah well i mean i think the whole
to be honest i don't even like the
ex-muslim term myself and
uh i i also thought i was an atheist i
was an atheist long before i was an
ex-muslim
but i think the term is really important
for us because
it's a way of challenging many ideas one
the idea that
you know muslims are a homogeneous
community and everybody agrees with isis
and the islamic state and
of iran and saudi arabia or the the
muslim council of britain
or the local imam no it's it's also like
any
group of people there are so many
differences of opinion in there there
are feminists in there there are
socialists in there they're atheists in
there
so saying ex-muslims sort of breaks that
idea that
minorities are homogeneous and descent
exists in our communities and we have a
right to speak out and criticize
ideas that we think are misogynist and
homophobic and inhuman
and also it's you know because
it's so difficult to criticize islam or
to leave islam
of course you know in i don't know 13
countries you can be executed for
blasphemy
in 11 you can be executed for being an
apostate
given that situation it's important to
say where ex-muslims were apostates
because it's a way of challenging it and
saying that
you know you say we don't exist or you
try to silence us when you do find out
that we exist
so this is a way of us coming out
publicly and saying
we exist and the public
renunciation is a form of resistance as
well you know so
from that situation it's important but
for me you know i come from an iranian
background where there is
quite a large anti-islamic background
backlash in iran
i mean it's you know the mullahs are
despised you know i mean there was a
funny story where
uh you know because our parliament is
full of mullahs right because it's an
islamic state
and he came late to the parliamentary
session and it was televised and he was
saying that
he couldn't get a cab dressed up as a
mullah so he had to go home and wear
street clothes
like a normal trousers and a shirt
before a taxi would pick him up to take
him to the
assembly you know so there is that
backlash so for me it was quite normal
to say ex-muslim atheist but when i
started the council of ex-muslims in
britain we couldn't find one non-iranian
you know to do it not one and of course
it's changed the world has changed so
much now
in because of social media it's changed
as if it's been a hundred years you know
that
everybody calls themselves ex-muslims
there are so many ex-muslims now so many
groups you can't even tell who's
you know where it started or when it
started but
that surprised me that there was so much
fear uh
for people who were born and raised in
britain that
really shocked me because it was so easy
for us from
coming from iran you know constantly can
i ask one question and then no yeah
and then this is a story uh that
happened at my school
uh before i joined and i remember my
colleague telling me about it and i
found it profoundly shocking it's a very
very distressing story
um so i used to work in a primary school
in east london
and one of the girls that we was at my
school she used to get the imam
to come and teach her and teach arabic
and islamic studies
one to one and it turned out that the
eventually that the imam was abusing her
and so the mum came in and the school
had to talk to her and had to persuade
her
to report him oh okay because other
because she didn't want to do it because
in once
in one sense she would be ostracized
from her community
and also the girl because she's had some
form of sexual contact
would be deemed to be impure and would
therefore be
again ostracized from the community and
i remember hearing that story
i just i just i don't think i've ever
felt that sad
yeah i mean i think it happens a lot i
mean it happens in the christian church
as well
yeah absolutely i mean it's so well
known and i think it's actually
maybe even more pervasive i would think
yeah you know
in islamic schools and mosques where
corporal punishment is norm
sexual violence sexual abuse i mean we
have
lots and lots of ex-muslims who've been
through things like that you know
and again the shame you know that's the
there is i mean i think it
it's also true for those who have been
abused in the church as well there is a
lot of shame and stigma
especially when it happens to you when
you're young you wonder
you know the shame of it was i
responsible whereas of course there's no
way
a child is ever anyone's responsible for
rape or sexual abuse let alone a child
um but i think there is that stigma like
you say and this fact that
if you come out it costs you so much
you know and unfortunately i think
i don't know there's this thing where
everybody's so worried about what
everybody else says
and what everybody thinks and there is a
lot of
times you know parents that shun their
children
um i wonder if they would do that if
they lived
outside of that community where they
weren't so worried about what people
would say and do
you know and so much of it is that
pressure so you're not just thinking
about your daughter you're thinking well
will people say what would they say
about her what will they say about us
um and more likely there'll be more
pressure on them than on the mullah or
imam or whoever yeah i wanted to
uh go back a little bit to uh
what you would you you criticize all
religion which i totally understand
um and you mentioned you know the
inquisition or whatever it might be
and there's no question that for example
at the time of the inquisition
the the islamic world was far more
developed and progressive in many ways
also they say yeah
okay but certainly if you look in terms
of
mathematics and architecture and uh
scientific
development and in some ways even
tolerance of non-believers
it was you could argue was more it was
more tolerant than the christian world
so certainly in that time you could say
quite credibly that
christians were being barbaric towards
heretics etc
and is it unfair to say that
now in the times that we live in now
islam
has the lead if you like in terms of uh
you know violence terrorism
uh oppression of women treatment of
minorities etc
is it not the case that right now in
this moment in time
islam is more extreme in those things
in terms of practice maybe in the books
it's all the same
but in terms of practice but you know
for me i think i
i would say well i focus on islam so for
me i think it is a major threat to world
peace and rights and so on and so forth
but i do think that it's
that all religions are capable of it and
i do think that
if they don't do it it's because they
don't have the access to power that
islamic states do but the minute they do
they will do the same i mean if you look
at for example the white nationalists
they uh their politics is based on
the bible for example and you know
in the u.s they've killed more people
than the islamists have
and we're seeing a rise of white
supremacists here in europe as well
and look at the u.s now they've got
states that are
outlawing abortion or making abortion
really difficult
so the more power they have you do see
the effects on women's rights on
on human rights on gay rights um
and you know and again in places in
africa for example
where children who are a bit disobedient
are considered witches and that
they're thrown out or they're made to
eat pieces of their own flesh
i mean these are things that the church
there for in nigeria for example
encourages so i do think that a nice
cuddly religion is one that has no power
and they're forced to you know do soup
kitchens and help the homeless and even
then
their sinister messages are always there
you know you you need to come to church
and then we'll give you some
food to eat you know come come for the
prayer session and then we'll give you a
bed there's always that sort of
attempts to indoctrinate vulnerable
people which makes it even more
outrageous you know
because it's people at their lowest
point that they're um
they're trying to help you know so
i think with islam we're seeing the true
face of religion
because it's got the power to do um
to put its you know what it practice
where its
thoughts are what about somewhere like
the uk for example
i think it's reasonable to argue islam
isn't the dominant religion of the uk
yeah we have we do have terrorist
attacks here and things like that
that we don't have from jews or
christians or whatever
uh and this is why i said we had lots of
questions that i we were kind of
reluctant to ask because
it's a very difficult thing i'm not
suggesting that you know all muslims are
terrorists or whatever but of course
but if you look up on the news and you
see a terrorist attack
in this country with the suicide bomber
you kind of know where that's coming
from do you know what i mean yeah of
course 100
i agree but uh i think for example um
the jewish settlers in palestinian
territories they are honestly they are
the jewish right you know uh and uh
the christian right that for example
killed the mp here in britain
cox yeah joe cox or uh for example
attacked
the mosques in new zealand you know
you've got you know the buddhist right
the buddhists are supposedly the
loveliest kindest people but they are
massacring muslims
in myanmar and um
sri lanka yeah or now
look at what's happening in sri lanka
after the attack on
the churches muslims i don't know if
you've seen some of the videos they are
so heartbreaking of just
muslims who are going about their
business being dragged into the streets
being attacked by mobs and their
buddhists who are doing it you know
a buddhist majority um and also
in india for example we've seen the rise
of the hindu right
you know how many people how many
muslims have been killed in india
uh for eating beef or for selling beef
because
the cow is sacred in india i mean it's
uh i was looking at a map
with all these dots of people who've
been killed it's a huge number we don't
even hear about it
you know and you've got hindu right uh
beating uh
couples who are celebrating valentine's
day in india i mean india is an
old secular state you know so these are
things that
we're seeing arise of that weren't there
30 40 years ago
you know iran iraq afghanistan it was
not like that 40 years ago either
you know if you look at pictures of our
countries it was completely different
so in 40 years look what they've done
you know they have made
life hell for so many people give the
hindu right 40 years
give the christian right 40 years give
the jewish drive 40 years it's gonna
they can do this exact same things and i
think that's why
it's important to focus on islam of
course but also not to forget that
the religious right if they have power
it can be
really really bleak for people um you
know everywhere so it's not just
islam and islamism that's the problem
one thing that has always baffled me
about every religion practically is why
it's so obsessed with
with homosexuality yeah i mean
so what i don't get it i don't
understand and it seems to be every
religion as well
yeah i mean it's interesting because i
think um
you know i don't know
obviously religion has this thing of
wanting to
make everything uniform of course but i
think it also comes back
i mean that's my take on it might be
totally crazy comes back to the
obsession on women
because you know they're concerned that
they might be attracted to another man
and well men you can't
veil and that's why men have to have
beards
and they have to be unkempt so you don't
mistake them for a girl and have sex
with them
you're doing great on that yes so you
know well you've got the beard yeah
exactly so
you're safe and that's why like the
taliban would actually
um arrest people and attack them for
not they would measure your beard on the
streets they had a cup where they would
measure it
and even donkeys had to wear nappies so
that in case you see the balls and get
all excited
it's like i'm saying religion is [ __ ]
up
and the fact that anyone makes excuses
for it and gives it respect i mean i
think it's worthy
of only of disrespect honestly and the
fact
that you know it's just when you hear
these things and you think my goodness
we're living in the 21st century
and these things actually you know these
are people's beliefs
and it's fine believe what you want you
have a right to it
but you know the problem is if it's in
the educational system if it's in the
law if it's in the state
then it makes lives really difficult for
so many people
[Music]
the one thing that i find is that when
we talk about these subjects i'll be
honest with you i'm sweating more than i
would do at the gym
without my bag of trench but here's the
thing
you know we talk about it this this is
an important conversation
it needs to be discussed it needs to be
discussed openly rationally
calmly yeah the problem is is we don't
have these conversations
because we're terrified right because
part of me you know when we go
where i grew up i was in the 80s and 90s
i remember salman rushdie i remember the
satanic verses i remember the fat one
that was put up against him
and then you know the you know the
extremists and all the rest of it
but also as well you know because we
don't talk about it
again it means that the tommy robinsons
of the world and the far right go
exactly okay i can exploit this
and because they're savvy they go well
no one's talking about it
yeah i mean that pisses me off though to
be honest because
when they say no one's talking about it
we
we fled our countries because we're
talking about it people are getting
killed and arrested every day in all of
our countries in the middle east and
north africa
because they're talking about it because
they're resisting very often women are
the front lines of it
and then you know they come and say
we're the only ones talking about it no
you're not
you're you know it's this first of all
that's a big lie in and of itself
because you know we've had the council
of ex-muslims we've had one law for all
we have the movement for unveiling in
iran we've got the
movement in algeria against sharia
courts we've got the demand for
secularism in
turkey by women's rights activists by
other activists there
you just name it you've got the
fastifying movement in morocco in
algeria
uh you know young people coming out and
smoking in the streets and being
arrested and being beaten but saying
we have a you you fast if you want but
we have a right not to fast if we don't
want
people have been doing that you've got
all these refugees fleeing
most of them are coming from islamic
states most of them are coming from
islamic states
why do you think they're fleeing because
they because
you know when you have a theocracy
everything you do becomes a challenge to
that state
how you dress what music you listen to
who you have sex with all of that
becomes political acts of defiance you
know
and and so all these people
are are having a say they're voting with
their feet they're they're resisting
even by doing personal things that you
know they deserve to do as
human beings living in the 21st century
and then tommy robinson comes and says
they're the only ones talking about it
well here's the thing with tommy
robinson right we get a lot of
criticisms because
lots of people want us to interview him
under this interview right now people
are putting comments
as they watch they go whatever
but one thing that tommy robinson fans
and supporters would say i think
accurately is the one issue that he did
talk about that a lot of people
didn't want to raise is the grooming
gangs that's not true you know how many
women's rights groups have been working
on that
you know on honor crimes on on fgm on
forced marriages
this is a woman's rights issue who the
[ __ ] is tommy robinson i'm sorry what
what defense of women's rights has he
done he's using the grooming gangs
in order to sort of say that you know
he's the only one speaking about it and
then he's done things that
could have jeopardized the court case no
but before that so
in my understanding hold on i could be
wrong yeah but let me just put this
counterpoint
right because in preparing for this for
interview i just wanted to kind of
understand the history of it so my
understanding and this could be
completely wrong but you tell me what
you think
is that he started the edl because uh a
cousin of his or something like that
was raped something like this right and
the the argument goes it was raped by a
muslim as i understand it
okay is that true because so much of
what he says isn't true so it's hard
that's my understanding yeah okay uh so
and in
confronting that fact in luton uh what
he found was there were lots of these
stories
of young white girls who had been raped
by
muslims and in doing so he then
discovered that this was happening
around the country
which he says is why he started the edl
and why they were protesting about this
and
when we say well no one is talking about
this i take your point that there are
lots of people who
were talking about this uh but maybe not
having the voices heard but he was the
one person that those two because you
see
the issues that you talk and let me i
just want to lay it out and you have
plenty of opportunity to say what you
want
uh an ordinary working-class person uh a
british person british-born
white person in oxford or in rotherham
or in luton
they don't care let's be honest they
don't care about what's happening in
iran they don't care about what's
happening in saudi arabia they care
about what's happening
in their community right so they might
say
that tommy robinson for all his faults
was the one person speaking up for their
daughters okay well you know
unfortunately i didn't know you were
going to ask this because i would have
done more research on this specific
thing because
we've done a report on the edl and
nowhere in its founding did it talk
about rape and rotherham and thing
so i think this is sort of historical
revision i would say
and i i'm confident enough to say it
because i know enough about them to know
that this was never mentioned initially
but because it's got traction now now
the whole history of
the edl is based on this but even if
that's the case and i
it's like outrageous and so sad if
anyone is raped and his cousin was raped
i think that's such a tragedy
but again you know placing collective
blame is what groups like tommy robinson
and the edl do
because for example i've had white
people say you [ __ ] foreign i get out
of the country and then if i start an
organization
that focuses on white people it's not
really addressing racism do you know
what i mean because it's sort of like
um to address racism
not only white people are racist first
of all there are lots of anti-racists
who are white
in the same way that there are lots of
muslims who are pro-women's rights
who are not raping girls and it's not
just a question of white girls being
raped they're non-white girls being
raped why is that also not an issue
that's something
we've been fighting for you know because
they only see britain as white
and christian it's as if their only
concern is for
white white women and only white women
who've been raped by muslims not by
other
not by the priests you know they haven't
started a campaign about pedophilia in
the church for example
i mean if you're concerned about rape
and child abuse and sexual abuse
it's something that is much more
all-encompassing as well
but i agree there has been this of
course a cover-up
we know that right we know that now the
police don't want to talk about it
even with fgm you've got the police
commissioner saying it's discriminatory
to talk about this it's targeting
a community well it's not discriminatory
for the woman who's been
mutilated it's bloody good if you do
something for her right
so i do agree that there is this climate
but i also think that
groups like tommy robinsons and all
they're not women's rights groups
you know they're using these issues
in order to further their cause and what
is their cause their cause is not human
rights it's not a defense of secularism
because really i think as a basis
religious and non-religious people need
to agree that we need secular societies
to protect both the religious
and the non-religious you know so
they're quite happy defending a
christian europe
a christian britain you know they have
no problems
with the church and its rulings on so
many aspects of people's lives
their focus is on islam because they're
anti-muslim and they're anti-migrant
and i think that's what my problem is uh
with them
they're using this issue and you know
like
what happened with the trial as well of
the groomers
uh you know what tommy robinson did
could have jeopardized the case and
that's quite crucial you know because
you want them to be tried
you want them behind bars you want the
full force of the law against people
like that
but it's not just concern it shouldn't
just be concerned for white girls
for all girls you know who are being
raped and abused but that that was a
it seems like that was a particular
problem within
one community right uh and i was going
to ask you do do you have any no because
i'm you know i don't agree no can you
imagine how many
non-white girls that those people are
raping i would think a lot more
because it's it's your property you know
in fact uh the the child marriages the
forced marriages all of that is sexual
violence against girls you know
but because it's their culture it's fine
but our white girls that's not our
culture so what you're saying is
a lot of those the statistics we see
about
muslim men raping white girls you
suspect that those
men were raping lots of muslim girls not
necessarily
i don't know not necessarily those men i
don't know because i don't know
but i'm saying the amount of rape and
sexual violence that's happening
to brown girls and black girls i can
i'm i'm sure are really high as well do
you know what i mean
and then there's so much rape and child
abuse taking place
it's not only that's just one aspect
absolutely and and that's the thing if
you're really concerned about women's
rights about girls rights
you know you would be a women's rights
campaigner you wouldn't just be focusing
on on that issue
that issue needs to be focused on of
course you know if people only focus on
that issue it's important to do it
so that's not my problem i think the
more people can highlight
what's happening and protect girls the
more that should be done
but what i'm saying is that it i i would
think it's historical revision for tommy
to say that
the whole edl started because of that i
think he's realized that
that's good traction for him because he
you know he does change his things he
says
he said the edl um you know he he left
it that's what he said when he went to
the interview with majid nawaz he left
it because
there were too many fascists and all
coming in but go and see his speech at a
pagida rally in germany where he says
you know this is this is what i was
dreaming of and
br the edl was came too soon and it was
too early for people to get it but
now you know now people are getting it
you know so
he he like a good islamist he also
changes his
speech for different audiences i think
you know islamists do that very well as
well it's called double speak
the far right do that brilliantly as
well they're part of the same movement i
think actually
you know islamism is a far-right
movement as well so i think
you nee you need to be careful and this
is the thing i was saying that
george bush says he bombed iraq for
women's rights
do we buy it we we don't just look at
what people say we look at what they do
how they do it in what context they do
it to to make up our minds about things
right
so with tommy robinson you know what
sort of work has he done in defense of
women's rights
you know why is it it always ends up
with muslims being deported and
you know less muslim migration to this
country
so it is a placing of collective blame
and i think that's
bigotry pure and simple you know i
understand what you're saying and the
reason i brought up the grooming gangs
yeah
is not because this is an issue that i
personally want to focus on exclusively
and i don't care about other things the
reason i brought it up
is that that from what i understand
from doing the research that i've done
and listening is
the grooming gang's issue is the one
issue that people
see tommy robinson as standing up
for their community but that was that's
today
that but before that it was him you know
and this is the other thing
this idea that he represents the working
class well look
a lot of working-class people join trade
unions they join anti-racist movements
they join progressive
uh organizing you know to say that
working class equates fascism
is just another rewriting and revision
of of
reality you know of course there are
working-class people who join the edl
there are middle-class people who join
the edl
there are elite people who are you know
top like one percent of society who join
and fund and support the edl or britain
first
you know they're getting a lot of money
including from the united states
christian right groups uh stephen
bannon's come to
europe to organize their groups and
things like that so
you know there's a lot of international
links just like the islamists have
a lot of international links founded by
the saudis supported by the iranian
regime
training's going on they're doing the
exact same thing so
you know the fact that it's then you
know working class
you know the working class is
automatically
fascist is not the case in my opinion
and also the fact that
uh believing tommy robinson at his word
i think is dangerous in the same way
that i think
when you have an imam coming into a
school or the muslim council of britain
saying you know we believe in women's
choice but meanwhile two groups of women
they're saying hijab is your obligation
you've got to you've got to be able to
be savvy enough to see what they say
what they're actually doing i think edl
politics
is so um divisive it's so dangerous
and mainly because it sort of has this
awesome them mentality which is exactly
what the islamists do
you know they're always dividing people
they're the kuffar
they're the muslims you know uh they're
destroying our culture
they're destroying they say the same
things as well you know they both hate
women they're both homophobes
you know fundamentally their their um
you know their focus is just
dehumanizing the other and i think
that's so dangerous because if you
kind of say look the muslims do this we
have to get them out of the country
you no longer see people as human beings
anymore you know but they are there are
so many good muslims you know
just like there are so many good white
people you know not all white people are
fascists right i mean that's common
sense
but the argument that the edl has is
that it's the muslims they're destroying
our country they're destroying our
culture it's
they're never citizens no matter how
many generations they've lived in this
country
you know so all of that is just so
dangerous and it doesn't really help
girls and women that's the point i'm
trying to make
in the same way that the islamists by
veiling and segregating they're not
protecting women they say they're
protecting women
but it's a lie it's there they do that
to dupe
people and i think the edl has the same
sort of arguments they
say grooming because they know that's a
concern for people
um but it's to do people into bringing
them into a politics of hate and
of scaremongering and of othering you
know
the other sort of dehumanizing the
others it's dangerous in my opinion
and i've got to say i i think the point
that you made and you made it
brilliantly and it's so powerful and
it's so true and it's really really
important
and because we always get people
commenting why don't you interview tommy
blah blah blah
and then the last comment is always
about how i look fat but there we go
it's always that why france is why are
you so fat your chin your mustache oh
come on man a lot of people actually
have been saying you lost away
yeah you've lost weight well tell them
uh the tv brings ten pounds
i'll tell you the body shaming is so bad
on this we had a we had a rapper on call
dubie he's a libertarian rapper and he's
yeah he weight lifts and he's got these
huge arms someone commented look how
good his arms are
you can you can see how good his arms
are by comparing them to francis and his
pathetic lack of definition
god everything so you know how women
feel
yes yes women are always you know
everything i i'm old i'm fat i'm ugly
yeah uh it's like and then if you're
younger well i've reached you know
because
isis used to kill women off after um 40.
because they couldn't sell them as sex
slaves right so i
should have been killed like 13 years
ago i'm 53 now
and so the the rape and the sex jokes
and all have changed to you all tag you
it's like
it's it's it's amazing how it's still
you know anti-woman but it's
depending on your age it changes so so
not that i'm happy that it makes me feel
a little bit
yeah i cried tears as i eat my chocolate
i think this conversation is it's just
so important and it needs to happen and
you know it's vital
but i could never imagine it happening
on mainstream terrestrial tv like the
bbc
in any great detail why do you think
that is
yeah i mean just a few days ago one of
my colleagues sadie hamid was supposed
to be on bbc women's hour
to talk about ramadan and how child
fasting is child abuse
and of course like one hour before the
show went live they cancelled her
uh coming and everybody on the show was
fine with child
fasting and it's happened so many times
i was invited to the bbc
uh during a campaign and this you know
usually i'm like okay
that happens but honestly after this
happened i just
cried for an hour because it was so
frustrating this woman was being stoned
to death in iran's aquineme muhammad the
oceania and we had a campaign in her
defense
and the bbc had invited us me to come
and speak about our campaign
and there was someone from iran saying
she needs to die
she's a you know murderer and then there
was a
sharia judge from britain who said well
stoning is good for society because it
purifies it
and they didn't they didn't have me on
and so you're the extremist out of those
three i'm the extremist but that's it
that's why it's like sometimes i feel
like i'm living in the twilight zone you
know
i'm saying she shouldn't be stoned to
that and i'm
and then they just cut me out and i just
thought you know there's a woman's life
at stake and they don't even have the
decency
to let me speak for five minutes i mean
i'm getting emotional just thinking
about it now
uh and also the fact that um you know
and their topic was should there be
stone should stoning be condemned
what what i know should standing but
but why why is that the case so it's you
know there's there's many reasons for it
there is
this idea that criticizing is akin to
bigotry and attack of muslims and i
think how offensive if
you know i'm offended on behalf of the
muslim community because
you know you think that this is them
they're barbarians you know you can't
criticize it because they would get so
hurt and offended and they chop
someone's head off
most people don't do that you know so
there's there's that
uh there's also um the fact that you
know they
they think this is the way they think is
that
because it's a minority you don't want
to that's under attack
or being discriminated against you don't
want to add to that
but you know we're all adults you know
we have discussions in our families all
the time yeah well there's a lot of
screaming and shouting
or you just try not to mention things to
survive the ordeal but
um you know people are adults they're
not as
sensitive as the media or government
thinks that they are you know so that's
another area of it
the other thing is you know we live in
an age of identity politics and cultural
relativism so
you know this is their culture you know
we are more civilized we can have
a chat about jesus and laugh when he's
wearing nappies but they
they just they go insane you know and
that's such a
racist view of people who are considered
muslims because
first of all not everybody is a muslim
there we have different
beliefs in all these societies including
lots of atheism
criticizing religion is a very strong
tradition
in a place like iran for example you
know we have
many many jokes about islam i mean it's
funny one of my
friends when he came here as a refugee
he went to an english language class
yeah
so the teacher english teacher was like
let's now all say a joke about our
countries
that we have for in our country so we
can share it so my friend was like oh we
have a really good joke about muhammad
and she was like
no no no no you can't say and it's like
yeah because we do have jokes like that
or we joke about molasses we joke about
muhammad we joke about
islam you know and here it's like you
know we become these people who
cannot do jokes but the problem there
mariam surely is that
if if i was to go on stage as a comedian
and do a joke about jesus
yeah wearing a nappy as you say i don't
have
any reason to fear for my life yeah
whereas if you make a joke about
muhammad you probably might
sure right yeah and that's the point and
i think when you fear for your life
that's when you need to make that joke
because that's when it counts
you know i i think that's exactly when
you need to do it and that's the whole
ex the idea of the ex-muslim movement is
that
poking fun at religion i think is hugely
important there's this
wonderful norwegian pakistani comedian
shabana rehman
and she's amazing she's like showing her
ass on stage and she's
uh sounds great to me i'm down well
because that's really taboo breaking
right i know it might not it might sound
stupid when i'm telling you
no no so taboo breaking and you know
there was this
event she was at and there's this
name is or something and he's like known
as the terrorist mullah in norway and
everybody was like really scared of him
and she went on stage and she picked him
up and she shook him around
and everybody burst out laughing and she
says you know when people laugh
you break the fear and that's exactly
when you need to do it and i think that
is so key like
making you know making fun and the other
thing is you know with identity politics
it's
become such that only if you belong to
that identity
you're allowed to speak but also not
even if you
belong to that identity because you've
got muslim women like yazmin rahman
saying something against child marriage
or against gender segregation oh she's
an uncle tom
you have to be the authentic identity in
order to say anything
and that means like if you're a muslim
you have to be pro sharia pro the veil
pro-child marriage pro this pro that
then you you can speak about it you know
so
the point is though that before this we
used to
believe in and the left was a banner
carry of this
criticizing religion freedom of thought
freedom of expression
and also it didn't matter what your
background was you work together for
social change and justice right
so i was an anti-apartheid activist that
was the first time i became political
right
um i wasn't black i was in south african
now i say something you know i went to
nor
to holland i said something about how
gender segregation is like racial
segregation
um in south africa it's
segregating people based on their race
and this is based on their gender it's
the same thing it's humiliating it's
dehumanizing
so on twitter someone said you're an nbp
or so you have no right to talk about
south africa
and i didn't even know what that was but
it means non-black person of color
you knew right what is this and i was
like
i was like you will not tell me what i
can speak about and what i can't
and i was an activist against apartheid
in south africa you're too young to even
know what apartheid meant
you know uh and it was uh and you you
have groups like south all black sisters
they're asian women but they call
themselves black sisters because
it's part of the black politics of that
time you know that it was
no matter who you were you worked for
social justice for equality movements
always for
women's rights has all been not about me
being superior to you but me being equal
to you
you know but now it's like you're part
of an identity you want to be superior
to everybody else no one's allowed to
talk about what you
you you know your your politics no one's
allowed to say anything
you get too hurt you know you've got to
use jazz hands you can't clap anymore
honestly it's become so absurd and i
think you know this is the time then you
have to just break
through things you know people are
always like don't you think you're going
too far
but this is when you have to go too far
you know that's how things change
if you just tiptoe around things nothing
changes you know
and so i think yeah jokes on islam
invite us we'll come and laugh really
loud
but but it's you know because now people
are trying to shut down those jokes but
it's like you said because
when jokes are essentially especially
that sort of joke is pointing out the
ridiculous
and if and if a beautiful joke like that
essentially cuts through
all the crap it's in many ways it's
better than hour-long speeches
because it's summed up in a 15-second
moment that everyone goes
oh yeah they laugh they're such truth in
jokes as well isn't there good ones
yeah and good ones and then there's no
comeback because when you just see them
a lot of the time they just get angry
and they storm off or they
they get upset yeah but it's interesting
to me that you criticize the left
because you're someone from the left
yeah
right yeah uh and yeah so i feel like
it's like a stab in my back
yeah i feel it as well yeah
they're fascists to me the islam is
their fascist i would never ever but you
know the left i think they should be
standing with me
we should be doing this fight together
and they've left us alone you know and
there's so many of us it doesn't matter
because
you know we're having an impact in so
many countries uh
and a lot of the fights against forced
marriage against honor crimes they're
all
done by minority women you know on their
own without
left the support that they should have
had and you were speaking at a
university in london a couple of years
ago
about some of these issues and you had
people come in and protest
and then the feminist society and the
lgbtq plus
a whatever letters there are yeah they
both came out in support of the
islamists who were challenging
yeah yeah yeah it was amazing because
these guys were so
threatening and they uh you know they
waited till my talk started then they
kind of
fell into the room and they kept like i
was talking and they kept walking past
me and hitting my notes and
i just could think everybody said i
looked really calm but i was just
thinking
i'm gonna just even if i have to just
read my speech i'm not letting them stop
my speech because if they do that's the
end of it you know then you can't go
anywhere after that
and i actually haven't been invited to
university for so long because they they
succeeded because people are so
afraid of of conflict
so the video footage is there where they
actually like one of them um did this to
one of our
uh activists and you can't see him do
this
but you see um one of our other
activists crying
because she is a libyan who was abducted
by the islamists for three days and she
thought they were going to kill her
and him doing this made her remember
that
so you just see her going like this and
then another time he went out of the
room and he was like boom
you know like just threatening stuff
like that and the video is very clear
that they were just so
threatening and aggressive right and
then imagine like yeah it just made me i
just felt like ow you know that hurts
that hurts these guys i don't expect
anything better from them you know
and but but that is like how can you be
a feminist and not stand with another
feminist you know
and to defend the most i mean he
eventually had to resign because
he um they found all these homophobic
tweets about him the president of that
islamic society and and still the lgbtq
plus society didn't say anything or
didn't retract their
thing they didn't apologize and the
university they contacted me 30 times
not to apologize but to tell me to
remove the video
and i said i'm not removing the video
that's the only evidence i have
um you know about what happened you know
and i thought
look at them they don't even have the
decency to say i'm sorry this happened
to you
because we're like you know when you
dehumanize the other to the extent then
nothing matters
i'm sure if i had been hit as well it
would have been fine i deserved it i
provoked it
and we saw that with charlie hebdo as
well they killed people over a cartoon
and you actually have people saying
well they provoked me you know well
islam provokes me every day
i hate it i don't come chopping off your
head or killing you
so obviously there are other ways of
dealing with these issues you know
but it's they've normalized it so much
that it is
um you know we are seeing i mean it's
amazing i go somewhere and they're like
the controversial mariam namazi and
yesterday they had
a an islamist who says that people like
me should be killed
but that's not controversial how did
what happened
you know it's it baffles me honestly
well that is a question that i think
baffles everybody yeah uh unfortunately
it's been
not unfortunately i was gonna say
unfortunately it's been a wonderful
interview it's been a wonderful
interview
but unfortunately where i have time
thank you so much for having me well we
have one more question for you actually
uh and the question that we always
finish up with is what is a one thing
that when that we are not talking about
that we really
should be talking about as a society i
think
is um seeing how
the islamists that everybody talks about
in some ways like
um uh is one and the same with the
white nationalists and the white
supremacists i think groups like
britain first edl the national front uh
in france for example they're very much
the same political movement
as the islamists and it would help the
left i think that's what i'm coming from
the left if they see how dangerous white
nationalists are
why can't they see that the islamists
are from that same movement
and then it would make them maybe
something would click in there
fossilized rotted brains of
multiculturalism and identity politics
what a great way to finish it what a
powerful image
that's great um if people want to follow
you
uh and your work are you on twitter yeah
sure mariam namazi is my twitter handle
that's so funny i hate saying that
i've got a website marionnamazi.com but
also of course the ex
council of ex-muslims of britain and one
law for all
you can see they've got twitter handles
as well and uh
on social media we'll make sure to tag
them all in thank you very much for
watching as always
we will be back in a week's time from
now follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
subscribe to the youtube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
i always forget something oh yeah come
and see my show in edinburgh it feels a
bit weird after this interview saying
that but
um called orwell that ends well about
free speech you're gonna do islam jokes
and if he doesn't boo him if you have my
permission
boom
[Laughter]
what a great choice but you're enjoying
it yeah and that's the most important
thing well i get fat shame to mate so
there we go
we've all got across the bear as it were
all right um
yeah uh leave a leave us an itunes
review uh if you enjoy it spread the
word retweet that be lovely i'm doing a
show here
in the bill murray in august i'll have
details on my twitter and
whatever else and um thank you so much
and we will see you next week
bye-bye some more comments about
france's being fat police thanks very
[Laughter]
much
here's the fall that you were asked to
say by signing this contract this is the
unicef on campus
soas right he was asked to sign an
agreement that his routine would not
contain racism sexism classism ageism
ableism homophobia biphobia transphobia
xenophobia
islamophobia anti-religion anti-atheism
if you're doing i think you're doing
some quite complicated mental arithmetic
to offset the fact that people didn't
think you were funny
i think the reality is these students
you have absolutely no sense of humor do
you feel like you're just
i mean you're just sort of being a bit
of an alt-right you know
all right we got there in the end
the good thing about being called the
nazi comedian right is i now got a niche
problem is i haven't got any racist
sexist homophobic jokes
the idea of being a student at the
university where you can't make any joke
about anything
because these poor little hopey students
get upset or triggered
get over yourselves it's not about
comedy it's about ordinary people
up and down the country and here in
britain and in america feeling like they
can't
say what they think i really don't i get
it i get it especially
especially the women who want to become
men i get it
do you remember when gareth bale right
went from tottenham to real madrid
the guy left a perfectly good club for
more money
everybody feels like we're we're all
kind of under arrest we're all
all everything we say can and will be
used against us in the court of public
opinion
and they're coming for the comedians
first because we're
we're the ones as you say are allowed to
transgress but everybody else feels it
and that's why the story's got the
resonance that it has
[Music]
you